The Swedish Chef is back everybody.*yayy*
Today we're going to cook...
(dramatic pause)
LASAGNA!
(wow-like effect in background)
But not just any lasagna!
Dead meme lasagna
à la Ugandan Knuckles everybody
That's right a new series
500 parts coming
(To Marzia) stop zooming
I can see you do it
Basically I was gonna cook lasagna
and I thought why don't we turn it into a meme?
So we're gonna try and make Ugandan knuckles
on lasagna.
So let's do this.
Let's freakin do this guys .
so let's do thi.. (laughs)
hehehehehe
Okay, step 1 wash your hands.
Dab on them germs.
Step 1(.1?) we're gonna make the mince
Oh, step 1(.2?), turn on the oven.
I knew that one.
I've done this before okay?
If you think that this is not going to go well.
Step 1(.3) you chuck the onion.
Now a lot of people don't seem to know how to chop an onion based on what I did last episode.
Everyone's like 'That's not how you do it'
This is how you do it, okay?
Unless you're a moron.
Now , the reason like onions is because of...
The layers – thank you, Marzia – which is why
We're making,
as you can see
a really good c-chomp.
[Pewdiepie] Such a backseat driver. [Mariza] Like this.
[Pewdiepie] Yeah but that's not how I wanna- [Mariza] Like that.
And then you do it like that, so then you be like that!
So Mariza doesn't know how to chop an onion, apparently.
Mm-hmm. This is how you cut onion. Okay, no big pieces disgusting by the way. I don't cry
Vikings – real Swedish people don't cry. Now it's time to
Cook it. Yeah now in Sweden we use
butter to cook our meals,
not some stupid oil.
Ignore everything!
Now, we grabbed what we in Sweden call a "kastrull". Dude, here's the thing
Why can't they design?
Like one of these for this called cutting board that like you can flip up the edges right so they can be poor the stupid
Do you feel this?
So basically right now we're making like the bolognese
Some of you guys were commenting that I'm using soy meat, like I'm some sort of soy boy. That's not it at all
I don't understand
Add the tomato thing
[Marzia] Is that the blood?
This is the blood of the Ugandan soldier
Make the meme spicy we need some thyme
And a tablespoon of rosemary.
There we go
Aaand a quattro everybody
Now let that sh– mix it nice and good we're basically just making Bolognese get some nice shots
Gordon Ramsey always has nice shots
That looks okay I guess
Fun fact about lasagna. In Italy it's not called lasagna
It's called what?
Pastitio.
Donde esta? Quel el emon...
That's not italian
This is gonna go on lower heat
Right
Hello
Next up we're gonna use not soy milk
To make the sauce some really good
manly sauce
Aren't you are you lucky to have some shit amazing shef melt the butter and then you add
The flour
I think and a lot of milk, one liter of milk
Really the thing about milk is that it boils when you're not looking?
It's what my mama always said
Shout to my mom
And then you gotta keep whisking it
Because
It boils when you are not looking
That's right, you learn fast Marzia I gotta say, very good.
Okay, I forgot you need to add one of these see that it's boiling and I was looking I was looking mom I swear now
I forgot to mention you wanna taste it as you go right make sure
It's salted and peppered correctly
Now we're gonna add the cheese in it
Which kind of....
Is that real cheese?
Yeah, which kind of goes against the point
Alright I like cheese, I'm just gonna add a lot of it
And as always you gotta taste it
(hehe) So hot
Done, done.
Looking fit, boy.
It's THICK. I added a little extra flour that was a bad idea, now it's all sticky.
Don't – hey tetetetettetetet
No one asked for a closeup right now, all right now for the fun part
The lasagna making. The Uganda making. Let's go everybody over there
Wait
– Food review
So making lasagna it's kind of like building Lego
Start off. I'm making a base
of lasagna, but also
how does it work with this I never–
Oh look how thick that is. Look at the thickness Marzia
You see that thickness? you get– you're getting the thickness?
this is what you might want it real thick. so you pour a quarter of it...
Evenly across as I'm doing right now, that was a little more– eh, it was perfect. I was perfect. as always
Now, same– same meme different sauce. Yeah
What?
Add the uhhh
The meat thing for that quarter, I think what am I doing, okay
And then just like....
That's it that's
It that looks beautiful. Just make sure it's evenly across, you know, just like that just like that another layer bazinga
Oh
Look at that
Pretty smart. Ooh, that's satisfying. It's almost like Tetris, look at that
Oh, did I say quarter I meant half.
Same thing same meme different songs evenly across my god, beautiful.
It's-a very nice, Felix. Why don't you say that you always say that
It's very good Felix you're doing such a great job. "Yob?"
Honestly, it looks real what do you mean
last but not least the last piece, you know, I'm gonna go a little crazy.
Are you guys feeling hugry at home?
I think I might have to use it tomato friend
Sure, do this face like this
Like this like fun
Wait, are you doing just a face to the whole thing?
Okay, let me start a little bit
You go in the pot at the body now he eats strong
Yes
If you're like a 40 year old mom and you want your kids to eat your lasagna
Just add the memes
Do yu kno da wae
He's beautiful
little smile
Which will definitely be there after...
I cook him. Now. Let's pop this bad boy in the oven
for a couple(marzia and poods are a couple)
Cup, he's gonna go off to Uganda everybody
All right, we've got 15 minutes left and yeah it still looks pretty decent
Incredible
And it looks edible too. Damn
You're supposed to make it wait actually make it wait. That's right. Let's get it
Do you know the way in five minutes you gotta you gotta let it cool down
Thank you for reviving me as a dead meme I hope this will serve you as a final, okay
It's beautiful. But what does it taste like now since I didn't put cheese on top you don't get that
BP but you know I got a ugandan knuckles on top, so. Don't worry about the consistency if you don't get it
Wow, that looks great, maybe I had a little bit too much sauce, but you know
Sometimes in life you gotta you gotta sauce it. Okay. Let's see how it tastes like
What it's really good but it tastes just like that one you can just heat in the oven
All right, let's see what the prin– the Queen says
It's good everybody it's good if you guys want to make it itself post with hashtag
Lasagne knuckles!